North Korea marked the 70th anniversary
of its founding with a series of
elaborate events it staged what it calls
the mass games in its main stadium for
the first time in five years and it held
a military parade in its capital without
displaying any intercontinental
ballistic missiles president Trump
praised the move he tweeted quote thank
you to chairman Kim we will both prove
everyone wrong
there is nothing like good dialogue from
two people that like each other Ben
Tracy sent this report from Pyongyang
North Korea despite the friendly words
negotiations to get North Korea to give
up its nuclear weapons are not going
quickly or well but instead of using
this anniversary to provoke the u.s.
with a show of force Kim jong-un appears
to be making some noticeable changes to
the North Korean script this is the
North Korea the world rarely sees tens
of thousands of its people putting on a
spectacular show
about unity and peace this is the more
familiar North Korea show but Kim
jong-un who watched the military parade
from above also ordered a plot twist he
significantly shrunk the weaponry
portion of the parade and did not show
off North Korea's most provocative
possessions its intercontinental
ballistic missiles
perhaps mindful of the fragile date on
between him and President Trump Kim Jong
hoon has used this 70th anniversary year
to make a major shift inside North Korea
yes the military and the missiles are
still important but what he's
increasingly talking about is building
North Korea's economy the majority of
the parade was about highlighting
economic advancements despite crippling
international sanctions our government
guided tours have been pushing the same
message
trips to a silk factory in a North
Korean cosmetics operation that exports
its products to China and Russia yet the
one thing that hasn't changed here is
the cult of personality around North
Korea's leaders past and present Kim
jong-un visited this teaching college
back in January and there is now an
entire room here devoted to his visit
they've even put this chair in a glass
case here because that's the chair he
sat in at the events this weekend Kim
waved to the adoring crowds people he's
not promising just better weapons but
also a better way of life
this is still a regime that is under
sanctions for brutal human rights abuses
so it's unclear if Kim jong-un really
intends to transform his country or if
all of this is just an elaborate
distraction for CBS this morning Ben
Tracy Pyongyang North Korea then Tracy
thank you I think there's been you know
some reporting on that - that despite
the fact that the ICBMs were not on
public display they still exist
the nuclear program still exists the
peninsula has not been denuclearize
there's still a lot more to do there
[Music]